So I'd like to ask you all a question
that I've pondered
for these past few years.
Why is it that for-profit organizations
and nonprofits,
or those that work
in the development space,
are quite different with the type
of impact that they have?
I mean, in theory,
they should be similar, right?
They both have access
to super-talented individuals.
Should it matter that you are working
on affordable housing
or trying to build a multi-million
dollar condo building?
I don't think it should.
But if I took a poll in this room
and asked you all to take a guess
on which of these buildings
will be completed first,
I'm fairly certain that we would all agree
it's not the affordable housing.
Right?
And you may go, “Well, Tolu,
isn’t it about the money?
One of these has access
to more money than the other."
And I think there's truth to that,
but I believe it goes
much deeper than that.
I live in Nigeria now,
before I moved back to Nigeria,
I actually spent the bulk of my career
working in development markets
in the for-profit sector, right?
In the for-profit sector,
we are held accountable
every year by investors
to ensure that the benefits
of the activities
that we invested in throughout the year
far outweigh the investments
in those activities.
This annual cadence of accountability
required that everything that we did
was striving toward
increased profitability.
This annual cadence of accountability
created such a high sense of urgency
in everything that we did.
And so we leveraged data analytics,
evidence-based tools to ensure
that we're able to hit those goals fast.
In the development space,
where I spend the bulk
of my time these days,
the culture appears quite different.
We don't seem to operate
with the same sense of urgency.
The work we are doing now
is arguably more meaningful, right?
We are trying to solve problems
such as increasing financial access
to those who currently don't have it.
We're trying to solve problems
that include education access,
energy access.
And, in fact, increasingly we are trying
to help people who are vulnerable
build resilience to climate change.
These challenges are quite significant
and require that we do things differently.
In Africa, we have a proverb which states
that if you want to go fast, go alone.
If you want to go far, go together.
But what happens
when trying to solve a problem
like increasing financial access
requires that you go both fast and far?
I believe that we need to do
development differently.
We need to include the profit motive
and for-profit approaches
into the way that we do development.
So let me walk you through an example
of how we experimented
with this in Nigeria.
We're trying to expand
financial access in Nigeria.
For those who don't know,
financial access
is an individual's ability
to get access to insurance
or loans or build savings.
A lot of research has shown, in fact,
that a lot of these development
activities that we have
require financial access as a key enabler.
A key enabler.
However, when you look in Africa,
we are lagging behind
the rest of the world
in terms of financial access.
In fact, in sub-Saharan Africa,
only about 55 percent of all adults
have access to financial services.
A country like Nigeria, where I live,
you have more adults in Nigeria
that do not have access
to financial services
than the entire population of Canada.
Think about that.
More individuals in Nigeria do not
have access to financial services
than the entire population of Canada.
Now, I mean, this is not
for a lack of trying.
We've been working
on this issue for a while.
And I think one of the reasons
the issue persists
is because we were trying
to solve the problem
in the same way we have tried
to do it in developed markets,
trying to build bank branches
and ATMs everywhere.
But this is so expensive
and capital-intensive and time-intensive,
which we cannot afford.
But there's a cheaper, scalable option.
Agent banking.
With agent banking,
a financial institution can hire
an individual or a retailer
to provide financial services
to the community on their behalf.
So you have ...
a grocery retailer, right?
She gets cash from selling
foodstuff to her customers,
and she can play the role
of a human ATM, if you will,
connecting to the branch online
and able to dispense cash to her customers
and other financial services.
And unlike bank branches and ATMs,
you can deploy an agent
within about a day.
So you can literally start the day
with the community
without financial access
and at the end of the day with an agent
provides financial access
to that community.
We know agent banking works.
And in fact, in Nigeria, we estimate
that over these past three years
we've deployed about 850,000
of these agents.
But the problem persists.
After all of this work,
the problem persist.
In Nigeria, we still estimate
that less than 50 percent, in fact,
of adults still have access,
despite all of this work,
and this has persisted for over a decade.
So a few colleagues and I
decided to investigate this
to try to understand why is it
that after all this work,
we're still struggling with this.
And so we teamed up
with nonprofit organizations
and for-profit organizations
to understand,
after hundreds of thousands of agents,
why does this problem persist.
And we discovered two important problems.
One is, we in fact, are not deploying
these agents into the right places.
The rural parts
and northern parts of Nigeria
most desperately needed these agents,
but the deployment tended
to be in the urban south.
And when we deployed them,
we tended to also deploy
overlapping agents.
What does that mean?
Think of this as
you are trying to, you know,
you deploy 50 ATMs
in a New York City block.
What's the point of that?
In fact, if you had used data analytics,
perhaps we would have done this properly.
The second problem we observed
was that agents, in fact,
were not staying around for the long haul.
So you placed this agent,
but the average agent only remained
operational for about three months.
Between the start-up cost
and the recurring cost required
to sustain the business,
they needed a high volume
of transactions, of business,
to be able to remain profitable
and remain in business.
But they didn't really know
how to do that.
So we're working hard,
but we're not placing them correctly
and they're not profitable,
so we're not moving the needle at all.
So with this understanding of the problem,
we wanted to design profitable
or viable agent banking business.
And to do this,
we did a compare and contrast
between agents that remained
around for the long haul
versus those that only left
after a short period
to understand the differences
between them.
We also literally went across the country
to understand the differences
of our agents,
who worked across the country,
and understand how money moved
in the respective communities.
And with this understanding,
we built our profitable
agent banking model.
So what are those things,
what are the key elements
to ensure that an agent is viable
and remains around for the long haul?
One is, you need to make sure
that you have about 500 adults.
You need about 500 adults in the community
to support one of these agents.
So when you are deploying
overlapping agents,
that can be counterproductive.
Another thing is, even though
these agents, in fact,
are leveraging the internet connections
to financial institutions online,
they still needed access
to cash for the community.
Cash was still very important.
And then, agent banking
is not a full-time business.
It's a side hustle.
So you can be a bartender,
you can be a grocery retailer,
you could be a hairdresser,
anything, really,
and offer agent banking
as an add-on to make that viable.
So we felt good that we understood
how to design it.
So now we wanted to estimate
how many of these agents
can we put across the country
to ensure that every Nigerian
has access to financial services,
universal access.
To do this, it's not a simple task,
involves a lot of data.
So we built an analytic engine,
called Geofin, to do this.
With Geofin, you can look across Nigeria,
any part of the country,
and zoom in to understand the current
level of financial access,
as well as how many
of these agents that we talk about
you need to deploy
to get to universal coverage.
So if you look down south in Nigeria,
in a place called Bayelsa,
in Bayelsa we have high level
of financial access.
About 85 percent of adults in Bayelsa
have access to financial services.
And so you would only need to deploy
about 2,000 more agents
to get to universal coverage.
Up north, in Yobe though,
in the northeast of Nigeria,
you find that about 25 percent,
only about 25 percent of adults
actually have access
to financial services.
And so there you need
upwards of 8,000 agents
to get to universal coverage.
Quite a beautiful tool that allows us
to sort of understand
and try to solve the problem
in a very nuanced way.
So all of this was research and analytics.
What did we find?
What was the real impact of all of this?
So you remember I had said
in Nigeria so far we've deployed
about 850,000 agents?
Well, with this approach,
we discovered that we only really need
about 275,000 more agents
to get to universal coverage.
Now, the bulk of these agents
were not profitable.
In fact, about 90 percent of them
are not profitable.
But that's OK.
The work they are doing
is still quite important.
And so we need to support them
with subsidies and grants
to ensure that they can stay around
and support their communities.
However, about 27,000
of these agents will be profitable.
We think of them
as the high-impact agents.
And what do they do?
These agents will move
the needle significantly.
So in Nigeria today, we estimate
that only about 45 percent of adults
have access to financial services.
These 27,000, roughly, agents
will move the needle from
about 45 percent today to 80 percent.
And given how fast you can deploy them,
we estimate that this will occur
within 24 months or less.
This is the power of including
the profit motive in development work.
That we can move the needle so fast
for a problem that has remained
intractable for so long.
Now, financial access is not
the only challenge we have.
What if we took this same mindset
to energy access,
where instead of just deploying
solar in rural areas alone,
we could think about helping entrepreneurs
to build viable urban solar businesses?
Or we can also deploy
this approach to education access,
where, instead of just
deploying schools widely,
we'll work with local community
entrepreneurs to build community schools
that are profitable and viable
for a long period of time.
I believe that when we combine
these nonprofit and for-profit approaches,
when we include the profit motive
in the development work that we do,
we can go fast and far together
to address these development challenges
and change the world for the better.
Thank you.
(Applause)